robbed you and I got to play some
advanced warfare multiplayer we did you
have to check it out at the review
events and got to try out some
strategies in like the small pool of
people before it goes wide for launch
and got to try some weird stuff out lots
of weird stuff know that stuff that like
maybe works a few days but then like
people figure it out and it doesn't work
anymore
exactly a lot of unique customization
options for loadouts and EXO abilities
that we got to experiment with yeah I
mean one of the things that I really
enjoyed playing around with at first was
the railgun
and you picture a railgun epic thinking
video games and it's like this giant
long-range sniper thing but this is a
pocket railgun it's your sidearm and you
get pretty early and it's one-shot kill
you know if you unless they're too far
away what's great about the railgun is
it's what you leave with right you run
around with that out hey you're running
a little faster and B if you land the
first shot on the enemy you see the
engagements over before it even began if
you plugged them real good of course
there's only one shot before you have to
reload so you pop them if you miss pull
out your primary it spray him down
that's a good tactic you put a little
red dot sight or a longer barrel on the
railgun and it actually becomes like a
pretty solid mid-range weapon so I
didn't get a chance to be this dude but
this guy was well he was pretty unique
and I'm calling him shield guy shield
yacht shield guy this guy I'm gonna
guess it involved shield that is correct
Chris shield guy shield up in front
shield in the back so he's grabbing the
heavy shield as a primary and then the
EXO ability shield and you too can
become shield man it was somewhat
successful well you it was hard to take
this guy down
was there also that factor of like what
the hell this guy doing he doesn't have
a gun it's got shields he's just running
around that doesn't make any sense you
can't do that
first reaction is yeah this guy is
intimidating and then you realize he's
got vulnerability and of course he's all
shield he's all defence he's literally
not going to shoot he's literally a
demon and you can take him down and I
did I sniped him right in the butt I
oh yeah speaking of sniping did you get
the tryout there's this one sniper bit
is like this weird two-shot explosive
system so the first bullet isn't
explosive but it doesn't blow up when it
lands you need to shoot the second shot
in close proximity to where you landed
the first shot and then the whole thing
blows up and if you manage to like plug
a dude with both shots he's gonna blow
up and anyone right drill close to him
it's also gonna blow up damn but if you
only hit him with one of the two bullets
it's not strong enough to take him down
so it's kind of a weird hybrid because
it takes more shots than the Moors or
one of the heavier snipers but it also
enables some interesting strategies
especially when you're talking about a
hard point or domination match because
you can stand with a sniper overwatch on
a position and people are trying to
occupy you fire the bullet first
explosive bullet into a wall or the
floor you fire the second bullet right
there boom you made a little explosion
in that area it's not gonna clear out
the whole point it's not a huge burst
but it is gonna shut down that area it's
gonna kill anyone who's in that little
corner and I was using it on the prison
level just like cleaning out that be
cellblock area a bunch it was actually
pretty effective weird even like firing
that first shot and then waiting for
people to show up did you ever do
anything anything like that yeah you lay
the trap right put it down there and
then just wait hold oh yeah yeah moving
on probably one of my favorite classes
that I kind of got to experiment with it
didn't turn out entirely successful but
it was something to consider which was
the invisilite sprint guy is where we're
gonna call him in visio knife invisi
nice V and V zone I've sprint guides
good considering perks like cold blooded
or light weight or any kind of stealth
perk yeah your footsteps are quiet right
that stuff so all I had though was my
knife and you definitely had increased
foot speed you were quick
it felt like some kind of psychopath you
know murderer just run around with a
knife so I'm - one moment on heart point
on the map riot everyone was flooding
into one front door and I like a clever
son of a B jump on the roof get behind
them and just start knifing them from
behind and it was
pretty amazing yeah for me the weirdest
sort of mess with your mind weapon that
I used was the laser beam yeah because
all right let's just call it what it is
it's a giant laser pointer so if you're
shooting someone with this beam
it's basically announcing to the world
what's up guys I'm over here hey shoot
the laser check me out maybe you want to
shoot me over here are you not sure
where I am see where this giant lasers
pointing yeah that's me right over here
guys follow it home it's ridiculous like
why would you even use this weapon but
at the same time when you're getting a
laser to the face when you're getting
blasted by it when you're seeing it
light up there's kind of this little
psychological effect like oh god I don't
wanna be in that laser you know your
brief edges gamers were trained like
lasers mean tripmines lasers mean alarms
lasers are bad to get hit by so it is
kind of like a a little bit mess with
your opponents you know weapon and if
you get some kills if you hose the guy
down for a little bit it's more of a
cyst friendly weapon yeah kind of tag
guys they run away they get a little
flustered and then your teammates mop
them up but it's really fun to kind of
play around with until you get tired of
everyone yeah it definitely happen to me
once or twice where I mean I had to go
on this one dude like an LMG just hosing
on him and he just hits me with a laser
and as you said blinded me it really did
he's all over your face get out of your
face like stop blinding me Jesus all
right so those are some of the the
weapon loadouts I think folks can look
forward to messing around with but a
really for me like the most fun thing to
just just go crazy with like right out
of the gate is the XO powers dashing to
the side doing the stomps doing them
double jumps do combining all that stuff
to just like make your mobility just
like really flex your mobility
definitely did you find that to be true
that was probably the one thing I was
really concentrating on which was
getting really frantic and juking out
people with those EXO dashes and by the
end of the day I was in love with it I
mean the fact that you can you know exit
out of a firefight as opposed to just
dying and having no ability to to change
or prevent a death was frustrating and
that's working out what's going on with
ghosts but
this it's just awesome lots of cool
moments like this in Call of Duty
advanced warfare let us know some of
yours in the comments below folks and
happy huntin happy honey